[موسيقى]
ومن كوخ اتخذه بديلا عن منزله يلخص
الثقافه حول التعليم في البلد فالثقاف
الذي علم اجيالا ماده اللغه العربيه وسرح
من وظيفته قبل 18 عاما يجد اليوم نفسه
ملقيا على الرصيف في وضع معيشي ونفسي بدا
اكثر تعقيدا نتيجه الحرب الحوثيه انا ساكن
في ذلك الكوخ لاني لا امتلك اي اي مكان
اخر غير
فكانت تلك ذلك الكوخ هو الوسيله التي
تحميني من المطار والشمس ومن عوامل الطقس
المختلفه كيف تم هذا الجو فتره الى ما قبل
الحرب والاحداث التي حصلت كانت الامور عاد
تمشي معانا
مع مصادر من بعد الحرب تغلقت كل الابواب
استوطن الرصيفه اذا وقبل به فاعتمد كليا
على اله العود على ان يقتات منها بشرف
يقول الرجل وتاره اخرى ينتقد الوضع من
امام مكتب التربيه والتعليم لعل رسائله
على الاوتار هذه توقظ اذهان المعنيين
لتصحيحه وضع المعلمين
زميلنا صبري السقاف الشاعر وكاتب وملحن
وعازف ومغنن وكاتب سيناريو له كثير من
الاسهامات في حياتنا اليوميه التي نتابعها
له في السابق اغاني وطنيه كثيره حاليا له
غانم انتقد فيها الوضع المعيشي ومرحله
الياس والاحباط التي وصل اليها المجتمع
اليمني
ليس الثقاف وحده من بات اليوم يشكو ضنك
المعيشه على ارصفه الشوارع بل تمت العشرات
من المعلمين يعيشون الوضع نفسه خصوصا مع
ارتفاع الاسعار وانقطاع الرواتب وتدهور
الوضع المعيشي في البلد يزداد الوضع
المعيشي تعقيدا في البلد ويضيق الخناق على
اكثر من 40 الف معلم ومعلم في المدينه هذه
امر بات يهدد باحتضار التعليم خصوصا مع
افتقار الطلبه للكتاب المدرسي وعزوف
غالبيه المعلمين عن المدارس والانخراط
باعمال اخرى كالسلك العسكري لاعاله اسرهم
هل سعيد العربيه تعز